is your flood lamp functioning properly  yeah that's working just will like these  stairs anyway thank you  please continue reason for stopping you  hear that there's a kid down there  sounds like could you please describe  the sound it's your a female or burger  boy it's crying sobbing saying please  help please yeah just keep repeating  that  crying can you estimate its distance  from your current location maybe 200  meters down please continue down the  next flight can you still hear the  crying yeah we're picking it up as well  please continue down stop if you notice  any changes in the audio or environment  keep going please  knocking then [ __ ] closer to that kid  noted please continue fill the money  you've spent a long time in a dark  unknown stairwell it's natural please  continue and describe what you see it's  some sort of [ __ ] person looking  right at me is it moving  no it's creepy  please approach and further illuminate  the entity